if you want to talk to other David
Pakman show viewers and listeners and
some of you may not and I would
understand that from the amount of
trolling that we experienced but if you
do want to engage in respectful
political discussion you can do so on
our subreddit at david pakman.com slash
re dee dee iti was browsing it this
morning found some interesting
discussions that I wanted to talk to you
about starting with the first one about
compulsory voting this is an interesting
idea and I've mentioned that my birth
country of Argentina has mandatory
voting and there are pros and cons we
could identify with mandatory voting
compulsory voting as it's also known and
an interesting discussion on reddit
about that also on our reddit discussion
forum a link to my interview with Josh
Zepps
I interviewed Josh Zepps on our show I
guess now it's been about two weeks and
I was interviewed on the Josh Zepps
program as well which is an audio only
podcast and you can now check that out
it's a full hour episode and we talked
about a lot of different issues you can
check that out on our reddit also on
reddit a link to an interview and I had
forgotten about this interview back in
what year was it I think 2014 I did an
interview with Bill share called what's
up with liberals on Russia and Putin and
in that video we discuss why there is or
that there is a strain of the left that
seems sympathetic to the authoritarian
rule of Vladimir Putin and it is really
relevant in terms of figuring out now
why there is this faction of the left
that might be resisting the allegations
of Trump Russia collusion above and
beyond what evidence is or will be
provided so check out that interview
someone thank you for posting it by the
way I'm glad that this was found and
lastly on the David Pakman show reddit I
was back on the Jesse Lee Peterson show
yesterday I got kicked off the air
actually and we will play that interview
for you in the interview segment today
but someone put together some of the
best screenshots from my last appearance
with Jesse Lee Peterson where I look
just downright sad I or I don't even
know what the the word is I would use
for how I look here Pat supported I am
experienced
disdain certainly for Jesse Lee Peterson
so you can check that out david
pakman.com slash read it and we will
have my full interview with Jesse Lee
Peterson in the interview segment today